- I love days where
I don't have to work
and I can just run errands
and look like trash.
- I know.
I'm not even wearing underwear.
- Yeah, me neither.
I mean, I'm not seeing
anybody I know,
so why would I?
- I actually probably should.
My dick always
pops out of these pants.
Ugh, I hate walking around
with toilet paper.
It's so embarrassing.
- Why? Everyone knows
you have a butthole
and poop comes out of it.
- Hey, you're okay.
- See?
She agrees.
- Hey, gay.
- Huh, not sure
that's about your butthole.
But, I mean,
I guess kinda?
- Wait, what is going on?
- Hey, you're the guy
from that video.
- Oh, no, sorry.
I don't think so.
- Yeah, the little kid's
music video
about his gay brother.
- What?
- Oh, um, Care,
look at this.
I think I found
what they're talking about.
- ♪ Oh, oh, oh ♪
♪ Hey, oh ♪
- ♪ My brother's brave ♪
♪ My brother's wise ♪
♪ My brother
doesn't like girls ♪
♪ He likes guys ♪
♪ He kisses men ♪
♪ That turns him on ♪
♪ And if you
think that's gross ♪
♪ Well, then I
think you're wrong ♪
♪ 'Cause I think it's cool ♪
♪ My brother's gay ♪
♪ And that's okay ♪
♪ The haters may hate ♪
♪ But I love how he's gay ♪
♪ He is so gay
in every way ♪
♪ My brother Cary is gay ♪
♪ And that's okay ♪
- ♪ Oh, oh, oh ♪
♪ Hey, oh ♪
- ♪ And that's okay ♪
- What the f--